les enfants ont là une belle surprise un
trampoline à notre faune et des fausses
cartes
encore mieux cette année fait décorer à
gauche et à droite à noël j'ai dû courir
des roches à drapchi à dos noir une
réunion de noël comme toute famille
heures mme harel en famille à l'eau
grand bakker mon père va critiquer tout
ce qu'on fait au père connaît pas encore
le nouveau dostie évoluer ses frais
d'optique et pression tout le monde
pense que je vais dire mais il est beau
comme le tueur
et approches la voiture s'il fallait
souffert je suis brad hawpe a pas mon
père arrive aussi et pour tous du rouge
pour que je me repère facilement dans la
foule
avec cette histoire de copa pas tu dois
demander la permission une autre homme
pour voir des enfants c'est salé comme
le rac entre moi et brad en fait on aime
les meilleurs amis vraiment brad merci
stop ça va parce qu'on est des gars une
fille j'y comprends rien voilà deux ans
le match tu dois faire en sorte d'être
celui à qui elle parle de ses problèmes
avec ses petits copains du moment ça
c'est la zone d'amitié d'accord non non
non c'est le pire conseil complice de
données tu veux être comme brad dans la
zone d'amitié ou comme ton père dans la
zone de touché
ça alors quel regard perçant vous dire
un velociraptor tu vois pas ce qu'il a
en tête
il croit que toi et moi on me jette un
mauvais coup non moi je me jette rien le
juste trouver l'arbre de réunions de
noël idéal roig connaît pas les scies à
chaîne
a battu tours de téléphonie cellulaire
il est mort en camp je crois je voudrais
pas passer noël avec ton seul vrai père
tu l'as fait venir ici juste pour te
venger de moi tu dérapes le feu sous la
mijoteuse brad we se crêpe le feu au max
elle va exploser
ça se corse j'aime ça
encore 5 minutes et c'est moi qui serai
joseph tu lances à l'éco papa c'est
terminé est ce que tu penses feindre
encore longtemps ou qui tente le go bad
c'est clair c'est pas un sportif
elle est peut-être coller dans sa main
j'ai quoi de ce titre vaut pas la peine
pour que huit en vaut la peine